dernière réunion et dernières mises au
point pour jean-yves blé le candidat à
la mairie de la verrière a réuni ses
soutiens pour un ultime rassemblement
l'actuel premier adjoint en a profité
pour développer quelques points de son
programme un programme établi après des
semaines de campagne ponctuée par des
ateliers et du porte à porte
on a parlé des sujets qui peuvent fâcher
parfois des sujets aussi qu'ils peuvent
être satisfaisant aussi parce qu'il y en
a heureusement et ça nous a permis au
fil de l'eau d'entendre ce qui va et ce
qui ne va pas et de construire ainsi
notre programme logement urbanisme
éducation ou encore sécurité
jean-yves bhl est conseiller municipal
depuis 2001 a ciblé près d'une dizaine
de thématiques pour ces élections
pour cette première campagne en tant que
tête de liste il peut compter sur le
soutien d'europe écologie les verts
avec son équipe il mise sur les
connaissances du parti écologiste pour
façonner leurs mesures environnementales
faire des campagnes de sensibilisation
dans les écoles essayer de mobiliser des
professionnels pour qu'ils expliquent le
bien fondé de cette question qui est
aujourd'hui fondamental pour pour tout
le monde pas qu'à la pac aux verriers
roi quand une ville se développe elle
respecte l'urbanisme se soit pas un
urbanisme sauvage dimanche prochain pour
le premier tour des élections
municipales jean yves blais sera opposé
à trois autres candidats